so how we have a quote here from author
David Sedaris ok pizza french boys from
brady pose ok that's where I get my
source time I'm keeping a diary for 33
years or so and I writing it every
morning most of its just whining but
every so often there'll be something I
can use later a joke a description of
quote it's an invaluable aid when it
comes to winning arguments and such as
like that's not what you said on
februari Thurid 1996 something like that
so you've mentioned in many interviews
that you've been a big david sedaris fan
and of course co chi is based on a
chapter right from yeah well suppose um
what is it about his writing it's so
fascinating what is about him it's
finally brought up his diary because he
does like when he says diary and when I
think diuretic like what just before
going to bed like you know like by
candlelight like right he keeps a
notepad on him and whenever anything
like strikes him is something memorable
he'll write it down and of the few years
I've known him there's been like one or
two maybe two or three times where I
like I've said something where he's like
laughed and ran it down and those are
like the proudest moments of my life
because you know if you're right and
even during when he saw the film at the
premiere he was like writing notes I
think that's a his way of sort of
appreciating something you know it's a
sort of making to make a note of it and
he but I don't have his work it's funny
because I for me I'd this story why I
like his work and why I liked the story
for a movie they're somewhat overlap but
at the same time that I like them in
different ways i think his voice is
unique and relatable at the same time
and i think that's really hard to pull
off and i think he set off a big like a
long generation on still ongoing
generation through this american life
through his work with ira like of a
whole group of people that can speak
personally you know of essayists really
i think he helped popularize that and in
a lot of ways not to say it didn't exist
before of course it's existed forever
SAS but i think the humor and the angle
and sort of the the approach he took has
inspired a lot of people and for me I
feel like the kind of life anecdotes eat
tells fit themselves or at least this
one did in particular to a movie it
doesn't they're smaller they're a little
i was interested in that to make a movie
that wasn't trying to solve the world's
problems and
an hour and a half you know that it's an
idiot admission but was still relatable
and funny but complex and those are the
kind of things i wish i could write
myself so that someone else already did
and i got the opportunity to adapt that
was um you know better than if i could
have generated it myself do you have a
similar voice as he you say you wish you
sorta kind of you know I I wish for it I
don't think I'm is clever you know I
don't think I'm I tried to in writing it
I tried to you know because there's you
know there's punch lines in it that are
my own there's a couple of particularly
proud of they get laughs and I hope they
fit into that tone you know I tried to
adapt it but I don't think i could write
and I don't like it right about myself
like he writes about himself you know I
don't like I was honest with myself this
is which is amazing how he can be so you
know you get his van he just goes away
and he can write about things so
honestly about how he feels about
something even if it reflects kind of
badly on him you know which I which I
really appreciate you know the not to
not have to UM you know glorify herself
I found that interesting and I wanted to
bring that into the character I thought
well maybe he shouldn't it's a younger
version of him so I thought maybe he
shouldn't be so likable maybe he hasn't
absorbed that self-awareness yet and
maybe this movie sort of about the
process of getting there when you'd
mentioned him prior interviews that
you've driven and you've done things
like you know pay for expensive tickets
to go see him yeah what were some of the
highlights of hearing him speak um you
know for me it was I first saw him I was
in college and I drove a few hours to
orlando see him speak and that was the
first time I'd seen speaking there's
something he's worth he's one of the
rare people that I would like encourage
people to almost like listen to the
audiobook is almost sometimes even
better than his written word because his
voice in his knee flexion there's
something so unique about it and there's
also like who other there's rarely any
other writer in the world that you can
go see and sit in a sold-out theater of
like thousands to watch read like that
doesn't really exist somebody does four
bands and musicians and and say and even
filmmakers to a certain extent but not
not really writer so there's something
about the communal aspect of like going
to see him read and the hue
he brings to it and his shows usually
have him reading his material and he'll
try out new material and and so you get
a little sense of his process and the
other half is a show or like q and A's
where he pulls out his diary and kind of
goes there and does that connect to what
people talk about and I don't know he's
just immensely entertaining like there's
something about that man died didn't
necessarily think the movie would
capture that you know he doesn't he's
not a writer in the movie he doesn't
read it doesn't you know that's not
really part of my intention but it is
part of me I'd Maury shin for and what's
one quote from do is the dares that that
really song had to the one I mean
there's there's tons uh what's the but
there's one there's something about
syphilis it's really funny I can't
remember I can't believe in forgetting
her it's all what I was quote but well
the one thing I did love that I thought
about a lot when I approached him and
wanted to make this into a movie he
talked about in an article he wrote
about the movie that was supposed to get
made out of me talk pretty one day I'm
back around 99 or 2000 that he
eventually decided that gets doing and
it was Wayne wing was gonna direct it
and there's a written script for it and
I've even read it it was kind of surreal
instruments so different than my movie
ever was strangely I think the woman who
wrote it had a film in competition at
Sunday SS here also so I didn't get a
chance to meet her but the world's
aligned a weird way but she but the the
but he read he wrote about the
experience of it be me being turned into
a film and he went to go see you can
count on me with his sister and
afterward she was I do you think they're
gonna make me fat in the movie I think
that's what she said and then he said
this great quote that encapsulated
everything I think how he feels about
the film or a film getting made was he
said I realized my fear wasn't that
they'd get me and my family wrong my
favors they'd get us right and um I
think there was something so sincere
about that I think so many people would
jump at the opportunity to like have
their life made into a movie you know
and you meet people every day we're like
my life sorry to be so interesting and
and I think what I really respected
about him was that he was so like no
it's not what am I gonna get from that
what is my what am I going to put my
family through on that and my approach
to him was one to really respect that
ideal which is I want to take this
specific story you know I didn't want to
make out David's it
this movie necessarily I wanted to take
of course that was part of the appeal
because I admire him so much but it was
this story you know was I felt it stood
on its own I felt it could stand on its
own away from his identity his family's
our characters and it they're not
portrayed on screen um so you know you
have all these elements that I thought
would lend him to to appreciating that
you know and he did and his sort of to
me has sort of what he communicated to
me was go do what you need like make
your own movie you know let go do what
you want to do with it and he didn't
really influence it or want to influence
it he's not really interested in the
film he's a loves films but he's not
just in the filmmaking process and so I
really took that to heart that quote of
his you know just sort of ran with it
and said okay I'm making a movie that he
happens to have written I'm not
necessarily I can't be indebted he
didn't want me to be indebted to his
identity or how he looked her how he
talks so I wasn't going to be so I
didn't cast them and it looks like him I
didn't tell him to act to his voice I
specifically told him to not really
watch him or try to mimic him or
anything like that I wanted the movie to
sort of be as much of my identity as it
would be David's so that's a long
incidents quote but what it's like what
the difference between I'll look it up
I'll look it up I'll look it up and tell
you it's not something I think the
difference between and syphilis in
the dictionary camera but it is it's
really it's like my favorite quote of
his but anyways you're looking for
sympathy you'll find it between and
syphilis in the dictionary that's was
wondering
you